[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front page is live here from downing
street time to see what's making the
headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer sonia soder and the daily
mail's deputy political editor john
stevens welcome to both of you here with
us from now until uh just before
midnight so let's take a look shall we
at the front pages and the financial
times focusing on what liz trust will
have to do to get to grips with the
energy crisis
the metro quotes from her arrival speech
we can ride out the storm the paper says
the telegraph carries those same words
and that is also the lead for the
express together we can ride out the
storm
the guardian says mistrust has vowed to
solve the cost of living crisis
while on the front of the eye economists
say taxpayers and consumers will have to
pay for the incoming government's
economic program
and the mirror responding to the
challenges faced by the new government
declaring now fix the britain you lot
broke
a quick reminder by scanning the qr code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages
optimized newspapers while you watch us
and listen to our guests so let's uh go
to sonia and john with the thoughts
first of all john you could kick it off
with the words um you know outside you
know everyone knew the weather could be
a problem here but she finally got
outside the words then of liz trust
outside downing street so a lot of her
speech she was talking about a perfect
storm and we saw that perfectly
illustrated we saw her from the sky
copter driving around around doing weird
loops around this part of london i think
it's possible that they were hoping that
the rain would ease off before she came
here they crossed over voxel bridge and
then back over westminster bridge and
it's not i don't know where she's going
whether she's going back to baltimore is
she coming to downing street she
eventually got here people put down the
umbrellas and she was able to give that
speech to the nation and the key theme
was clearly about she's going to get the
country through this storm that is the
energy crisis and saying how she's going
to come forward with her plan to help
people with their bills on thursday this
week absolutely there's so much work to
be done we've seen it already underway
tonight the cabinet appointments some of
them in the last half hour or so
will there be a cabinet committee
meeting tomorrow will it be then that
they hear the plans before they're
announced perhaps a day later is that
the schedule i think it will be
something like that anna and when you
look at the cabinet that she's put
together there's a couple of things that
stand out
one is that she's really promoted
heavily her backers now of course in
some ways you'd expect that but she
didn't win by quite the margin that
people were expecting so i think there
may have been some on the tory back
benches that thought she may have she
should have given a few more seats at
the cabinet table perhaps to people who
supported her
competitors she hasn't chosen to done
that do that it's going to be
interesting to see if that means that
she gets to want a tighter ship or
whether there's going to be a lot of big
beasts on the back benches who kind of
um who sort of rally against her so i
think we'll be we'll be we'll be seeing
the consequence of that but it's all
about this energy package isn't it
what's it what it's going to say there's
been a lot of speculation in the press
yesterday and today we haven't got the
details some very big price tags going
on it the household bits meant to cost
at least 100 billion another 40 to 60
billion for um for businesses
potentially in public services so it's
these are really big ticket items and
it's very different to what you were
saying during the conservative
leadership contest absolutely right out
the storm been picked up as you saw by
many of the newspapers at the suggestion
possibly was that the energy price
freeze would kick in at about two and a
half thousand pounds uh 400 pounds is
being paid also two people uh that
announcement by rishi sunak earlier this
year is that what you're hearing what
more details can you share with us and
what we're likely to hear on that i
think that is right that they are going
to fix the energy price gap for average
households that was at the moment about
1 900 pounds was due to go up to about 3
600 in october they fixed it at
500. and as you say you'll get that 400
pounds of extra help so it's
almost the same as it is now just
slightly higher so that will make a big
difference to people but that's
obviously going to cost a lot of money
and we've seen a complete change of tact
from liz trust it's only a couple of
weeks ago that she was saying that tax
cuts was the way that she was going to
deal with this that she was going to do
her reversal of the rise in national
insurance which can look at corporation
tax which obviously affects businesses
instead but that she was against
handouts and now we're seeing her
spending absolutely vast sums of money i
think that's just because she's realized
there's no other way to deal with this
that if the tories went into the next
election with people having electricity
and gas bills they were up to something
like 4 500 4 000 5 000 pounds by the
next election people just can't cope
with that and i think that's why she's
realized realistically you do actually
need to take something that's very
significant in the way you are yes and
business closures failures as well has
been a real problem there there's the
front of the ft then trust this human's
office with the vow to steer britain out
of the energy storm the question is how
how the markets react the eye beginning
to pick up on that trust era begins with
a tax warning can you add a cutting
taxation to the amount of borrowing it
looks like you're going to do what
happens to the pound what therefore
happens to interest rates economically
this is
there's no prediction yet how this will
go it's huge uncertainty and i think you
know we've seen we've weathered quite a
few financial crises as a country over
the last 15 years or so there's a 2008
financial crisis the financial impact of
the covered pandemic was obviously huge
but this is even bigger that's what a
lot of economists are saying and i think
the impact that it's going to have on us
in the long term on the long-term
structure of the economy and long-term
interest rates nobody really knows yet i
think a big question for trust and her
agenda we've just been talking about it
is that so now we've got maybe you know
100 billion plus on the table in terms
of support to households and hopefully
to businesses as well but she also she
won this conservative leadership
election by by promising a hugely
expensive program of tax cuts economists
think that her tax cuts could cost
upwards of 50 billion pounds a year and
it's kind of a bit like how do you make
these things sit together because when
you look at the nhs when you look at
schools they need more money more
government spending not less because
they're facing the same pressures as
everyone else wage inflation they've got
to find money for teachers salaries out
of their own budgets the government's
not stumping up for it and rising energy
bills and the nhs and schools are big
consumers of energy so how does how do
you do massive tax cuts just at a time
when public services need more money to
keep running we managed to catch a chat
with jacob rees-mogg who was delighted
to be given the role of business
secretary he's already been we know uh
in those discussions with some of the
energy companies to try and
lock down this plan if we can put it
like that um where do you see liz trust
because sabina jenkins was certainly
saying today that she's literally got a
couple of weeks and that could make or
break her premiership do you see it like
that i think that's exactly it and
that's why she's come out so quickly
with the plan i mean we have been
waiting all summer for the tourists to
get on with their leadership contest so
we can work out what help people are
going to get but that's why you have
seen her fly straight down here from
band mall say that she is going to
announce her plan on thursday and that
they're going to come straight out the
traps with that i think if they'd waited
any longer then there'd been much much
much more criticism of them it's
difficult for her though isn't it she's
talking about growth when a recession is
predicted she talked in her speech that
we can see there about prosperity for
younger generations when it could well
be their saddle with even more borrowing
debt this is you know there's a tight
times the words are not going to match
probably what she has to do it's a
hugely challenging economic time so
you've got the um you know the really
acute crisis the ukraine energy crisis
that's been caused by the war in ukraine
you've got really long-term issues in
the uk actually our productivity growth
has been the second slowest in the g7
since 2008 and that's because i think a
lack of investment in skills
infrastructure all that kind of stuff
and then we've got a massive housing
crisis as a country and you've got
growing numbers of people in their 20s
and 30s who would just never get to own
their own home and we'll be renting for
all their lives it's really hard to see
how the government is going to sort that
stuff out when we've got this very acute
energy crisis that you know one of the
most worrying things about it is we
don't know if it's going to be over next
year or the year after it all depends on
how long the war in ukraine goes on well
a bit of a word there from the daily
mirror now fix the britain new lot broke
trust enters number 10 full of promises
just like the last three tourium uh pms
i nearly said mps there they've been
that many haven't there
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me once again sonya
soda and john stevens welcome back both
of you uh vicki ford has just left and
got what role she's a minister of state
at the foreign office looking at
international development so we're
already at stage where ministers are
being appointed she really is rattling
through so let's talk in more detail
shall we about who is in and who is out
some certainly some big names falling by
the wayside including the former deputy
uh prime minister dominic raab but who's
in and and the importance of some of
those faces there that for the first
time ever the top four greatest officers
great officers of state are not held by
a white man yeah and it's quite
incredible actually when you take a step
back and look at it we've got two black
men in two of the great offices of state
as in the treasury and as foreign
secretary then we've got suella
braverman an asian woman um as home
secretary and then we've got a woman as
health secretary and deputy prime
minister so i think for the first time
in our history we've got a female prime
minister and a female deputy prime
minister and um you know obviously
that's quite separate from their
politics and what you think of their
politics but i do think it's very
striking when you look at the diversity
of the cabinet that she's pulled
together and i think there'll probably
be some people in labor looking at that
and feeling a little bit uncomfortable
because the labour party does not have
the best track record when it comes to
putting women and people of color in
senior positions yes we know don't we no
we were used to resets of the sort of
the organization of downey street under
boris johnson many of them forced upon
him of course that has also happened
today has it not um you know a big
change in the way she run things
suggestions that more will be devolved
to the to the cabinet departments is
that what you've seen so far i think so
and you have seen a big change in the
ministers all those people who are close
to rishi sunak they're basically all
gone i think it's possibility that by
the end of the night we only have one
person who supported rishi sunak around
the cabinet table we're expecting that
to be michael ellis the attorney general
we think that's the job he's going to
get but she has had a real clear out all
those people we expected people like
dominic rahm to go he said that her
economic plans were electoral suicide no
there's no way he could have carried on
serving but people like grant shaps the
transport secretary we think he was
quite hopeful that he would have managed
to cling on in there but no they've all
been cleared out they've all gone and
also quite surprising when you think
about the result of this leadership
contest let's trust one with 57.4
which is a perfectly good result but
it's not really overwhelming it's less
than boris johnson got it's less than
ids scott is less than david cameron got
and so for her to kind of really stamp
her authority and say i'm in charge now
i'm picking people who are loyal to me
then that's a bit of a surprise that
she's gone so far when she didn't
actually win by such a big margin well
there's only one winner isn't there
there's only one person who would get on
that plane fly to belmoral to meet the
queen the son picks up on that hello liz
as both of them say that to each other
obviously maybe even at the same time
absolutely the kissing of hands which
isn't really a kissing of hands the
moment yes the moment when you're coded
otherwise
just uh 30 seconds left for both of you
top priority for
the new administration sonia first
quickly it's got to be cost of living
but i think social care is a really big
one too i think clearly it is energy but
you look at how much importance she
seems to be putting on the health
service making to raise coffee deputy
prime minister and health secretary she
mentions a lot about health but it's
less clear how you manage to sort those
problems out there isn't a load of
excess money around you can't really
throw money at the problem and saying
things that are going to cut bureaucracy
people always say that but it's not
really a magic wand to get people to be
able to see their gp